- FREE AT LAST,
FREE AT LAST,
THANK GOD ALMIGHTY,
WE ARE FREE AT LAST.
[cheers and applause]
- LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
PLEASE WELCOME
YOUR NEXT SPEAKER,
THE REVEREND ROBERT JONES.
[moderate applause]
- [whispers]
HOW AM I S'POSED TO FOLLOW THAT?
I CAN'T.
NOBODY CAN FOLLOW THAT.
HOW AM I S--
I CAN, UH...
OH.
[feedback]
ALL RIGHT.
[shrill feedback]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
UM...
THAT--THAT IS THE--
THE BEST SPEECH I'VE EVER HEARD
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
[chuckles]
EVER.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD
A BETTER SPEECH.
[chuckles]
AND NOW IT IS MY TURN
TO SPEAK.
HUH.
[chuckles and stammers]
WHO PUT THIS RUNNING ORDER
TOGETHER, RIGHT?
YOU KNOW, UM,
DR. KING, UH,
HE--HE ACTUALLY COVERED
A LOT--
A LOT OF WHAT
I WAS GONNA SAY.
UM, YOU KNOW, MY--
MY SPEECH IS, UH, UH--
YOU GONNA
FIND THIS FUNNY, Y'ALL.
MY SPEECH
WAS ACTUALLY CALLED, UH,
"A VISION FOR THE FUTURE."
I'M NOT SAYING THAT DR. KING
COPIED MY SPEECH.
I'M--
[crowd murmurs]
NO! NO!
NO, I'M--I'M--
I'M SAYING
I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
I'M NOT SAYING
HE TRIED TO COPY IT.
YOU--WHY DON'T Y'ALL LISTEN
TO WHAT I'M S--
[murmuring intensifies]
WOW. YOU KNOW WHAT?
[crowd booing]
NO, COME ON!
I'M JUST SAYING.
IT'S A JOKE.
DID I NOT SAY IT
LIKE A JOKE?
OK--
NO?
APPARENTLY,
I HAVE SIX MORE MINUTES.
HE, UH, GOT THAT OUT THERE.
[chuckles]
OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
ALL RIGHT, HERE--
HERE'S SOMETHING--
HERE'S SOMETHING NEW.
HERE'S SOMETHING BRAND NEW.
HOW--OKAY, THIS IS OFF--
ME TALKING OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD HERE, EVERYBODY.
UH, WHAT--HOW ABOUT
IF WE LET, UH, BLACK PEOPLE
ENSLAVE WHITE PEOPLE FOR--
[crowd boos]
OKAY, YOU KNOW,
THAT SOUNDED A LOT BETTER
IN MY HEAD
BEFORE I SAID IT.
[booing continues]
SO THAT, UH,
THAT WOULDN'T WORK.
IS IT WARM?
IS ANYBODY ELSE WARM?
WHOO!
- OKAY, OKAY, OKAY.
HERE'S WHAT WE GONNA DO.
ALL RIGHT, DR. KING
TALKED ABOUT, UM, UH,
ALL THE RACES COMING TOGETHER,
RIGHT? RIGHT?
SO WHAT I WANT EVERY NEGRO
TO DO HERE TODAY
IS FIND THE NEAREST WHITE PERSON
AND GIVE 'EM A HUG.
JUST--JUST GIVE 'EM
A HUG, OKAY?
NO, SIR,
YOU'RE NOT BEING ATTACKED.
YOU'RE BEING HUGGED, OKAY?
EVERYBODY TAKE IT EASY HERE,
OKAY?
EVERYBODY RELAX.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE DON'T NEED TEN NEGROES
HUGGING ONE WHITE PERSON, OKAY?
LET'S JUST--LET'S--
YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE NEW RULE.
NOT TEN ON ONE.
ONE ON ONE.
SO WE'LL JUST TAKE TURNS
AND EVERYTHING, OKAY?
SO EVERYBODY RELAX, OKAY?
[crowd shouting]
[glass shatters]
OH, MY GOODNESS.
SIR, SHE DOESN'T NEED
TO BE DEFENDED.
SHE DOESN'T NEED TO BE DEFENDED.
SHE'S OKAY.
SHE'S OKAY, OKAY?
[crowd screaming]
ALL RIGHT, MA'AM--OKAY--
OFFICER,
IS THAT NECESSARY?
I DON'T THINK
THAT'S NECESSARY, OFFICER.
[sirens wail, horse whinnies]
NO, MA'AM, PLEASE!
[dogs bark, women scream]
PLEASE TAKE IT EASY, SIR!
EVERYONE TAKE IT EASY,
ALL RIGHT?
THEY'RE JUST HUGS.
YOU'RE NOT BEING ATTACKED.
[loud screams, sirens wailing]